the award for cinematography will be
made by an expert in the field of
photography the vice-president of the
Eastman Kodak Company mr. Edward Curtis
since we don't want to hide anything
from you the Eastman Kodak Company takes
the position that film is a necessary
element in the making of ocean pictures
sometimes our justice have been quite
candid about this accepting view however
does not keep us from admitting the
first law of photography without
imagination a motion picture camera is
about as useful as a hip pocket in the
Garden of Eden and the latest lens would
be nothing more than a drollery from
upstate New York happily there are
people of Maj ination men who have
managed to delight and edify us with one
single frame of film
they've given us 50 years of images to
treasure 10 of them are in contention
here tonight the nominees for the best
achievement in black-and-white
cinematography are Sam Levitt for
anatomy of a murder
Joseph Michelle for career Williams C
Miller for the Diary of Anne Frank
Charles Lang jr. for some like it hot
and hairy straddling senior for the
young Philadelphia the winner is the
Diary of Anne Frank William T Miller
graduations - thank you very much thank
you very much
the nominees for the best achievement
and color cinematography are Robert L
searches for Ben Hur League arms to the
big fisherman Daniel L fat for the five
pennies France planner for the nun story
and Leon Shama Roy for Porgy and Bess
and the winner is Ben Hur Robert L
searching
thank you all very very much